[Music]
this is star talk sports edition we're
doing an entire episode on
neuroprosthetics and I don't even know
what that means because I'm like my
co-host Gary or Riley
came up with this and created a show
around at Gary how you doing man I'm
good Neil thank you excellent excellent
and you come to us from the UK If the
accent didn't otherwise give that away
former Soccer Pro and current
professional soccer commentator so we
love that about you and every third show
I want to remind people that we see your
sexy legs in a photo on your wiki page
you have your own Wikipedia O'Reilly
Soccer Pro so we've got you there
um Chuck doesn't have a Wiki page yet
but we're working on that Chuck Nice how
you doing man what's up Neil how's it
going all right all right hey man we're
all good we're all good so so Gary just
give us the overview before sort of we
introduce the the guests because what
all right here we go what prompted this
and where's it going uh all right
spoiler not a lot of sport in this show
and I guess our audience will be cool
with that once they realize where it is
we're going to go with this
we're going to take them somewhere I
hope they really want to go to but in
the now in 2022 people with limb
paralysis or amputations
can restore some of their movement with
the aid of Prosthetics you know
something like a running blade or some
more sophisticated electrical
engineering robotic Tech but think about
this what if
you could hook up a human brain
interface and then found a way to record
neural signals and decode them to learn
our very own neural language it's been
done it was called The Six Million
Dollar Man
this would enable Chuck a prosthetic
user to control ever more complex
movements
just by thinking in a brain machine
interfaces or if you prefer
neuroprosthetics are taking the world of
biomedical engineering
to a new place and that place is exactly
where we are headed in this show okay
none of us have expertise in any of this
right other than the fact yes other than
the fact that we I presume have brains
that's about us where the that's where
it ends well speak for yourself exactly
all right first off we have Dr Cindy
chestek associate chair for research in
biomedical engineering associate
professor of biomedical engineering at
the University of Michigan in Ann Arbor
where she runs the cortical neural
Prosthetics lab which focuses on brain
and nerve control and fingers so that
side of this subject is covered
on the other side is Dr parag patil
associate professor of neurosurgery
neurology
anesthesiology and biomedical
engineering again at the University of
Michigan his focus is neurosurgery with
emphasis on neuromodulation therapies
for movement disorders so we are really
going to get into this deeply and wow
these are our guests okay that is
beautiful welcome guys to StarTalk
thanks for having us yeah and I see you
you work in the same institution so you
guys like work together I presume
correct
absolutely I I do not do surgery all
right right that's correct yeah so we do
the engineering and you have strongly
overlapping Venn diagrams in the mission
statements and I think that's where
that's where all this matters matters so
I want to know just each of you just
briefly tell me how you let's start with
power
um Park how did you get interested in
this
well so uh it actually when I was 12
years old I saw Star Wars The Empire
Strikes Back and there's a scene where
Luke Skywalker gets his hand cut off
yes exactly you did first I find out
you're my father then you take my hands
okay
there you go I was a small town kid
and uh and uh a couple days later there
was an article in our paper about a
computer-controlled knee and that was
being done at MIT and basically the 12
year old me said I want to go there and
I want to do that well that was in the
80s and we weren't quite ready and it
took me uh I guess 40 years to get to
the point where we're actually
developing those kinds of devices you
said it was a computer-controlled knee
it at that time yes there was a
professor named Robert Mann who was
working on a computer assisted knee now
this is back when you know computers the
laptop hadn't been developed yet so it
was it was quite an accomplishment well
yeah so a knee that was like Big Time
stuff
I'm just thinking
if if all you bring to this show is a
knee I'm thinking we got the wrong guy
right so I'm assuming the the field has
moved well beyond the knee since since
the 1980s I presume now I was going to
say a a knee is like kindergarten
compared to a hand right right right
like I mean am I am I wrong when I say
that the hand is the most complex moving
part of the body is there anything else
that has more complexity since its
movement than the hands yeah I mean
depending on how you count there might
be 20 degrees of freedom in here right
like how many how many of them you
actually use when you know you're going
about your life is is debatable there's
very few things I do that require you
know all of them
um but yeah no it's extremely complex
and no way to make a robot right now
right like the for anything that
requires the human hand Prague doing
surgery you know assembling lots of
things we still have the hand and that's
that's the most advanced motor
controller we have right so just so
people just were on the same page tell
us what you mean by a degree of freedom
yeah okay that's a very engineering
thing right and so we want to know what
that means okay so it's sort of moving
along One Direction of movement and I
need to have full control along that
Dimension I need to be able to stop
anywhere like I need true Freedom along
that line right and and that's my degree
of freedom and so you know your thumb
can explore probably a three-dimensional
space so I can call that three degrees
of freedom sometimes we control the
thumb as a two degree of freedom but
it's it's a consistent direction of
movement and I have to have full control
along that degree of movement so be up
down left right forward back and I think
twisting is also a degree of Freedom
right rotation yes yeah yeah so for
example yeah so like you know the
orientation of a point so technically to
control the whole point you need six
numbers or six degrees of freedom
rotation and the XYZ right right okay so
while we're on the explanation cycle
here um what is a brain interface system
a BMI
um what what what is that about what how
does that work yeah so yeah that
definitely requires some unpacking so a
brain machine interface is where we
record from the brain we apply
algorithms to interpret that brain
activity and then we use it to control
some kind of external device for example
like a prosthetic hand or we we also
stimulate um if you have like a
paralyzed muscle you can you can take
brain signals and you know turn them
into stimulation commands for a
paralyzed hand
that's pretty well this is Dr
Frankenstein you bring something back to
life that you had no movement
yeah I mean it's more like I love that
Cindy was like
quite characterize it that way
yeah thanks Neil
um much better looking
it's more like fixing a broken wire
right like if you have a spinal cord
injury or an amputation you know it's
there's the signals are perfectly good
in the brain you just have to somehow
get them where they're going and so you
know it's replacing that that descending
path that's what the neck electrode
nodules were for in in Frankenstein's
and Frankenstein was that what they were
for I didn't know
is like this listen I just work on
brains in real life thank you so is it
what is the difference between a brain
machine interface system and a
neuroprosthetic is there any difference
is it the stem thing are they completely
different here and mean I think
prosthetic is used very widely for
replacing any function that you know if
you're placing a function with
technology people will will call that a
prosthesis
um a brain machine interface I think is
when you you're connecting it to
something outside the body you also hear
brain computer interface so if you're
just controlling a computer mouse or or
things like that then it's you know not
necessarily a BMI
um but you know in my lab we mostly
control physical objects yep I got a
question for you so I'm I'm going to be
last in line to start hooking up
machines to my to my brain just so you
know last so when I when I think of
what's going on in the brain things are
happening on a on a chemical molecular
scale we don't have machines that are
that little to interact in the way my
brain normally functions so what is what
is the mismatch
that you're trying or let me not
pre-bias the answer okay so how are you
taking machines and aligning them with
the neuroelectrochemistry of our brains
that that's a great question Neil so so
the brain actually is two different
systems that are operating together
so you have all of these cells little
microscopic cells that have all these
chemicals in them and proteins and kind
of the biology of them and they're
producing electrical signals and so you
can look at the brain in two different
ways you can look at it as the chemistry
and the chemicals that are moving around
and you can look at it as the electrical
signals what Cindy and I work on
accesses those electrical signals
oh so you don't you don't need the the
the the biochemistry if the
biochemistry's sole purpose is to make
an electrical signal because you can
just put in the electrical signal
because we got that we kind of can the
thing is that that means that's a polite
no I think the trick is you have to put
the right signal in the right place at
the right time the right signal at the
right time it's a two-way street oh of
course and you have to know what you're
reading if it's written in a foreign
language it doesn't do you any good and
we don't know what the language of the
brain is yet so how do you create that
Baseline and do you find variation from
brain to brain because brains tend to be
very different from one person to the
next so how do you create that Baseline
and then how do you account for any
variations
yeah so so the the short answer to that
is it's a machine learning problem right
like you know you'd think think we would
need to understand the brain at a very
low level to be able to do this but we
can just use correlations right so if we
have somebody coming into the lab we say
Okay move your thumb 10 times move your
index finger ten times you know and then
we learn that relationship and we're
only recording from a very small number
of the neurons like there's there's many
many neurons in the brain we get to look
at a very small number of them and we
have to deduce that relationship
think of it like you're uh like your
iPhone your iPhone recognizes your face
but does it really know your face does
it really know it's you no it has a
computer program in it that says Ah
that's the face that I've been taught to
recognize and turn on and that's kind of
what we're doing
so the moment there's no Rosetta Stone
no good point here code breaker for
people in your field to be able to just
go this is what this means because that
would mean you'd have to standardize it
you'd have to localize it to every
individual brain you'd have to oh every
brain would have to go through some uh
brain interface standardization for that
person training yep yeah no and you're
trying to get that down to the smallest
amount of data but basically if you you
know you're looking for the same kind of
pattern over and over again and then you
relate that to the different movements
but yes every single person that gets a
brain implant there's a whole
calibration routine and they think about
all these different movements and we
learn what that is so are are the motor
cortices of the brain centrally located
or they like other parts of workings of
the brain where they're in different
spots
the Prague question so luckily he knows
where to find these signals
how many brains have you poked at let's
get that up front yeah let's uh yeah so
I I guess I wouldn't quite use the term
poking but but uh you know I I would say
on average about a maybe a a hundred a
year over the past 17 years wow and then
a bunch of spines as well all right the
technical term for that and how many of
them have you turned into your own
personal zombies
[Laughter]
nope there's no zombies I'm afraid so uh
that I'm the doctor that you never want
to have right one who wants to happen
you want to have a pediatrician you want
to have you know a primary care doctor
but but you don't want to have a
neurosurgeon no you don't okay 100
brains a year for 17 years and Gary what
did you call that
related to the the question we were
talking about before so the the brain in
some sense motor is distributed so we
have different parts of the brain that
contribute to the motor plan and then
signals Converge on something called the
motor cortex which kind of sits about
here and those signals go directly down
your spinal cord to your muscles and so
the the trick is not only
uh operating the muscles but figuring
out what you want the muscles to do and
that's what the rest of the brain is
doing so you said here some people will
only be listening to this via podcast so
what part of your head were you pointing
to I I was pointing kind of just above
the ears if you drew a line from the
kind of halfway up your head over your
ear to your eyeballs that's roughly
where the motor cortex sits got it so Dr
chestick
how are you using assistive
exoskeletons
to help recapture the use in a person's
hand who might have damage might be an
amputee and how is that process linked
into the work that you do so we actually
uh Gary we've got to take a break when
we come back we will lead off with that
question uh Dr Cindy chestnick and her
collaborator Dr parag patio who we have
just learned has been inside the brains
of thousands of people Prince start talk
sports edition returns
we're back StarTalk sports edition we're
talking about neuroprosthetics with
doctors Cindy chestnick and parag patil
Cindy's an engineer and parag is a is a
medical surgeon and they're both focused
in the same way
with the same mission statement and uh
we're trying to learn more about what
the present and future of this brain
machine interface is and we left off
with a question Gary why don't you give
us that question one more time okay
um came across the term assistive
exoskeleton right and I was I'm thinking
well how is that going to work how is
that
set within your program because it's
looking to restore and recapture the
movement in a hand of someone who's
damaged or an amputee so if you could
explain how that fits in
movement back so if we're talking about
an exoskeleton we're probably talking
about spinal cord injury and paralysis
and and trying to help somebody that
can't move right now as opposed to for
example a prosthesis or a prosthetic
hand
um but yeah it's we mostly in the lab
are trying to stimulate paralyzed
muscles
um but you can just actuate the hand and
we we do also you know sometimes just
you know use a Servo motor to move the
Fingers
um and that's some that's another way of
of trying to restore that movement yeah
but if you do if you do with Servo
Motors then you're not doing it
neurochemically within the the nerves or
the hand itself correct no no and I mean
let me let me maybe take you through the
system a little bit um you know so we
record from the brain we get maybe like
a hundred tiny needles worth of
information
um you know we process that needles that
are inserted in the brain in the brain
wow yes and and you're right sign me up
yeah you're asking earlier about
detecting the signals it's really it's
not as hard as you think it's more like
milliseconds and microns is the time
scale in the space we got that yeah so
it's not that bad we've got you know if
I if we get our signal within like 50
milliseconds that's going to feel pretty
instantaneous if you're trying to
control something
um so another second is not a millionth
of a second it's a thousandth of a
second
yep correct okay yeah that's about the
time scale of neurons signaling to each
other so how long are these names how
long are these needles
in the skull into the brain are they
attached permanently or they just you
just take them out it's it's like
acupuncture I mean I mean it's about a
millimeter right that goes into the
brain and that gets you into you know
the really great signals but are you are
you keeping those in on a permanent
basis yeah so how do you overcome
going through the skull into a brain
that is floating freely yeah yeah do
these people have like skulls when this
is happening
so I'm sorry
but it was just a fact of you you if you
had any slight impact on that patient
while those needles are in there you've
got all sorts of issues to overcome Gary
they're not playing football while this
is happening what do you think what do
you think these people are someone can
bump into something it's okay happens we
make the woman answer the question okay
this is actually a parag question okay
why you can have tiny needles in your
brain safely so so we've we've we've had
over A Century of being able to get into
the surface of the brain safely and for
patients to heal up well and be able to
even go home from the hospital the same
day or the next day these uh electrodes
really rest on the surface of the brain
but they go in just enough to be able to
record the activity of the cells so
don't think about it as something going
deep into the brain even though that's
something I do with deep brains
stimulation helped hence the name but
this is something that's resting right
on the surface and then you're right the
brain is soft and so there's a very
flexible wire that comes up to the
surface where we can then attach it to a
uh something that that can take it to
the computer and this is through a hole
in your skull that you have drilled with
like a drill bit
I was hoping you would say no we have
more inventive ways but that's just a
blunt yep yep get it get out our Black
and Decker drill and go in welcome to
this old brain
we don't do remodeling so wait a minute
so
um I guess for either one of you when it
comes to the exoskeletons that are used
for like lifting things and sure you
know uh you know because they're already
in existence how are they communicating
because we're you're telling that what
to do with when you move your arm that
exoskeleton goes with your arm so how is
that machine receiving a signal
yeah I mean you know short answer is
circuits right and every time we use a
different output device we gotta you
know build a little circuit to control
it I can tell you that some of the
biggest problems we run into is if that
thing you're controlling is not totally
following your thoughts or what you want
it to do you lose that sense of
embodiment right so for example
prosthetic hands they're just not that
fast yet right and exoskeletons just
they're nowhere near the performance of
the real arm and so you're trying to you
know maintain that sense of embodiment
by doing a good job on the prosthesis so
the idea is that you know to
to take that
um sensation of a phantom limb and make
it the actual limb yeah I think that's
right that's right that is a win
condition yeah yeah okay okay okay and
if you did that right they can use it
the very first time they pick it up
right and it's gonna feel like they're
real hand but saying we're there yet but
that's the goal just about so we're on
the same page parag please tell everyone
about Phantom limbs because Chuck just
slipped that in there but that's an
actual thing right yeah so so so Phantom
limbs basically are when you feel a limb
that isn't there and there are a couple
of ways that that can happen if for
example you lose your arm you might have
the sense that your hand is clenching
even though you no longer have a hand
and so that's Phantom limb what Cindy is
talking about when we talk about
embodiment is similar to that but
importantly different so when we let's
say we're using a pencil you're writing
something with a pencil back in the days
when when people use pencils and it
almost felt like an extension of your
body so you didn't have to think about
it as an independent object what we hope
to do is reanimate the hand and the arm
so that
the person paralyzed paralyzed hand in
arm the paralyzed
so so that it feels like their own again
right
all right let me ask you this question I
mean from my own experience of surgery
being done to me you get Scar Tissue you
can't help it now Gary have you been
operated on your brain
now that was a waste of time
less pointless operation
surgeries there's partitions okay yeah
so even if you're inserting and please
tell me how a large or small if you like
these these micro electrodes really are
if you're going into this through the
skin and going into spinal columns if
you're going into the chord if you're
going into the brain you are going to
encounter scarring so how is that
affecting how these electrodes operate
so this gives me a great excuse to talk
about what I would say is the most
science fiction thing my lab does
um right now the electrodes that we're
putting in are on the size scale of like
50 microns right and that's big for
something that goes into the brain
you're absolutely going to develop a
scar around that and that is limiting
the performance so you know to get a
micron there would be 50 000 of a meter
correct yeah yeah so so 50 microns you
really need neurons to be within 30
microns and actually I'd love to talk
about the physics of this if you have a
neuron within about 30 microns you can
see the little check marks every time it
fires a spike on your signal Scar Tissue
pushes that away right if I grow a scar
around that electrode those neurons get
farther away that's the hardest thing
about making these systems
um what you know my lab and others are
doing to try to get around that problem
is we're making wires that are smaller
than neurons right so my lab uses carbon
fiber carbon fiber is one of the
strongest materials we have access to as
engineers and we can make something that
is less than 10 microns but can still go
into the brain and then that there's you
know yes there's still some scarring at
that point but it's dramatically less
wow if you're smaller than the stuff
that's going on in your body your body
won't even know to make Scar Tissue it
sounds like all right that's the hope
and I mean eight microns is still vastly
bigger than the kind of wires we have in
computer you know microchips right
things like that so like it's not it's
it's a solvable problem there's there's
a design space where you can make
something small enough to go in but big
enough to get the signal out okay so
you're overcoming the scarring issue
fantastic
you can't just put any material into a
human body so you've got to find
biocompatible materials so unless you
don't like the patient there is always
like that
why Chuck is not a medical doctor
yeah that's fair enough but you see so
where have you gone where have you gone
for biocompatibility what what materials
are you finding the most effective here
yeah so I mean there's wonderful
materials scientists working on this but
we have a really good menu to work with
so you know we work with carbon there's
all kinds of like organic polymers that
are in medical devices
um your body actually really likes
things like titanium and platinum yeah
right so there's a lot of medical
devices made of those materials
um and so that that's sort of our menu
and it's it's good enough there's a lot
of like you know good conductive
materials good insulating materials
um people are making small devices out
of uh glass packaging that does a good
job of protecting electronics and so
yeah I'd expect to see a lot more
devices that go in the body you know
over the next 10 years
wow all right so parag if if you've got
a damaged spinal column right and there
are no signals coming out of that how
can you place electrodes in that area
just can you guess or do you or do you
bridge it as an animal suggestion
yeah so so this is a really exciting
time because as you can hear technology
is advancing computational speeds are
advancing and so our options are growing
and so one option is to get signals from
the the brain and to operate something
like a electrical stimulation of the
muscle another option might be to create
a jumper cable in the spinal cord and
people are actively working on all of
these because in the end we don't know
what the right answer is going to be and
what the one is going to be that's
easiest to solve people are trying to
use new materials to bridge the gap to
let your own cells grow and reattach you
know there are lots of different
approaches and so I I would say that the
approach that Cindy and I are taking is
an excellent possibility but it's
certainly not the only one so when you
when you're Harvest I'll call it
harvesting these signals
from a patient's brain how how are you
interpreting what check marks present
themselves for you to be able to go
right that's going to mean in ones and
zeros someone picking up a pen someone
holding a cup of coffee someone waving
so how are we interpreting these things
that's where sin came yeah so there's a
lot of steps along that pipeline so you
know we start with a voltage the voltage
has little deflections in it that mean
when the neurons are firing we then have
to turn that into some sort of summary
signal so we you know you can just count
up the spikes like for some amount of
time and look at firing rate of neurons
um then that's when you need your your
training data so you need to say okay I
know this set of spikes is for this
movement this set of spikes for this
movement
um and you know usually we're running
something like a regression right which
is where you know you're basically
trying to get these you know one set of
signals to predict another set of
signals
um or we're learning some kind of
probabilistic model like you know it's
like what was the odds that I saw these
10 spikes you know when you're moving
this direction and you know and then
well then there's even more circuits
right because then we have to turn it
into something that goes in the
prosthetic can so it's I don't know it's
a fun engineering problem and there's at
least five or six steps down that
pathway and that's all trying to
reproduce you know what was normally in
the spinal cord so in engineering and
statistical problem right because it's
uh the distribution of cause and effect
with signal and phenomenon has to be
modeled right and that this is this is
your job and your people the better our
model is the more likely it is that that
when you when you go to grab the door
so wow and that's challenging so if I
could take away one challenge
that you have to overcome to get to
perfect restoration of movement
in a hand with all of the what I would
call typical finger movements and some
movements what would that be what would
the biggest challenge that I need to
remove right now for you yeah so the
other is probably not intuitive I need
the body to not destroy my devices oh
right like anything you put in there I I
can't make like we know how to make tiny
Electronics we don't know how to make
tiny electronics that can live in the
brain and not get attacked right it's
like a hot salty water kind of
environment right and if I could just
make things survive forever we could
make things very small and you know and
get them what you need is a cloaking
device
you need to be you need to be able to
couch the technology inside of something
that the body thinks is itself
if we could also teleport that'd be
great
and then we wouldn't need parag anymore
warp drives yeah just go down the list
you know okay so the the body the body
has a self-defense mechanism and you
know phases aren't set to stun etc etc
to carry on the Star Trek analogy
just how long does this stuff last in
the human body are we talking days
minutes weeks months years the goods the
good news is that the lifespan is
measured in years um I just saw an
article in wired they were talking about
you know the new record being said at
like a seven year implant that's still
functionaling pretty well
um so you know it's it's pretty good but
of course you know if you're going to
get a brain surgery which you definitely
only want to do once you're going to
want to last for a very long time yeah
yeah seven years is not a it's not a
good right you don't want to be singing
you don't want to be seeing a
neurosurgeon every five seven years it's
uh it's I mean that that in itself is
traumatic to have to go through that
amount of surgery particularly in that
part of the body okay so there's still
something under I don't understand so
um Cindy it sounded like you uh you gave
this one like that's the only thing left
to resolve but but the two of you
working together are you saying you you
have
succeeded in exactly what you intended
did you recreate Luke's hand did you you
know what are the successes maybe that's
really what I'm asking here
I think Cindy uh Cindy nicely talked
about the major engineering challenge
which is the brain machine interface and
I would say from the biology side we
still don't understand the language of
the brain we don't know when we are
recording all these signals what are the
signals telling us and so that's a whole
we need the Rosetta Stone uh you know as
Gary said we need the Rosetta Stone for
the brain to understand what these
signals mean
right so is that is that basically the
hard yards of research and going through
patient after patient after patients and
just making AI work a 28-hour day
yeah I mean I would say my perspective
is slightly different on that where like
I totally agree we do not understand the
language of the brain there's so many
wonderful neuroscientists that are
working on that but
quantity has a quality all its own
so if we could solve the engineering
problems you know oh my God thousands I
think it's Napoleon say that say that
quote again
quantity has a quality all its own
beautiful so if you were to give me a
thousand stealth microelectrodes that
the brain you know was not reacting to
I'm pretty sure I could get a lot of
these degrees of freedom moving even
without necessarily solving the language
just because of the power of machine
learning yeah but uh parag the you can
we've been focusing this conversation on
movement so the the kinetics of the
brain human intentions but what about
thoughts
and where does it how is it thought a
pure thought different from a thought
that creates movement
so that's that's a great question and we
we don't have the answer so people are
also working on these kinds of
interfaces to reproduce language for
example you put the electrodes in the
language area of the brain and you try
to interpret what a patient who is
unable to speak is trying to say
um right okay and also those thoughts do
have I don't know how to put it it's not
a tangible quality but a miserable
quality for like I read this study about
how they put these people in an MRI and
they did things to them just thought
wise and their brain lit up like it was
actually happening
you know so that that there is that
element of it too wow yes so so that
comes in where we're trying to think
about where to put these electrodes so
imagine someone is paralyzed so they
can't move how do we know where in that
particular patient's brain the hand area
is located what we do is we have them
think about moving their hand and their
brain activates in their individual hand
area which gives us some sense of where
we need to go even though that hand area
has lost its electrical connection the
hand area of the brain has lost its
electrical connection to the actual hand
correct so so now Rippy just completely
trippy
the chain you if you lose the electric
connection then the representation in
the brain changes it might just like
when someone has a stroke other areas
take over those functions you might
rewire yeah yeah and so some of that is
also happening okay so then how do you
account for that kind of neuroplasticity
that uh you know it seems like the brain
is always changing which I mean so
you're always trying to hit a moving
Target Chuck put a pin in that we're
going to take a quick break and when we
come back we're going to find out the
answer to Chuck's question and I want to
start bringing up sort of the ethical
issues here poking around in people's
brains to change what they're doing and
maybe even one day what they're thinking
that's part of the neuro was plasticity
neuro stick any word after neuro and it
will apply okay when we come back the
star talk sports edition
we're back star talk sports edition
we're talking about the brain with two
brain experts and I love it we got one
coming from the biology side one coming
from the engineering side and uh these
are the folks we need to get their heads
together and figure out uh what the
future of the human brain interface uh
the brain machine interface will become
and so Chuck we left off with a quick
question of yours uh what was it I'll
paraphrase it was it that we know the
brain rewires itself from stroke victims
and through other sort of brain can be
opportunistic so that it doesn't
completely lose abilities uh from an
injury versus what it can recover from
so how does that plasticity interfere
with your data uh yeah so if it was a
brand new brain every day this would be
really really hard so luckily we don't
have to deal with that I can I can count
on things being very very similar from
day to day even though we do have to
recalibrate all the time because lots of
mundane things change from day to day so
there's some base truths bass truths
yeah like it's you're more or less
seeing the same signals from day to day
um but of course yeah of course the
brain can change and there's really like
two schools of thought in how to do a
brain machine interface I'm like the
machine learning club right we're just
going to use lots of algorithms you know
same things they use for autonomous
vehicles there's also like the
plasticity club right and they're gonna
try to figure out how to unlock the
brain's natural plasticity and you know
surely I control my own brain and if you
just give me my own enough practice with
it that I'm going to be able to control
anything with it then we just go around
the problem and then the problem is not
a problem anymore then it doesn't matter
where you put the electrodes yeah yeah
you just rewire you just go you just
wire around around the brake break yeah
okay yeah so wow that's pretty cool let
me ask you how long before this these
neural interfaces once we get our
Rosetta Stone once we crack and code
our signaling how long before this is
common medical practice and if it is
will it be limited to just your motor
skills or will it have applications for
neural damage in the brain uh senses
or hearing us or even more importantly
augmentation oh yeah of course yeah how
long before we're bionic yeah yeah yeah
this is one of those Wicked problems
that that you know if if you asked me
when I was headed up to college if I
would have something like this that you
know has all this information I can
reach all my friends with the record
show he held up a smartphone yes a
smartphone yeah
um the uh I I wouldn't know and and so
the answer is we're making steady
progress and I think that devices that
are brain machine interfaces you know
you could see them rolling out in the
next 10 to 15 years but at what point
will we have something that we want to
control our wheelchair in traffic
that's the question so there's a
question of reliability as well so we're
making steady progress but we don't know
and there may be jumps uh in technology
that we haven't even imagined yet that
are going to be fundamentally important
to what we're trying to do but but right
so the the future of this is is sky's
the limit right because you're here
working on on motor skills motor ability
at all but you're still
poking the brain I'm sorry you didn't
like the word poke your uh you're what's
the word you're exploring probing
policing an electrode
okay so when I think of all
of the reasons why people are are uh
institutionalized for mental health
reasons
if once you Cindy once you know the
brain map you ought to be able to go in
and Nip Tuck cut paste to change
whatever might be a completely
regressive societal Behavior into
someone who who's a perfectly
law-abiding citizen otherwise or
perfectly behaving in ways that we
consider normal but then again who
defines what's normal
yeah so I yeah I agree in a sense what
we're developing is Technologies for
interfacing with the nervous system and
the nervous system does all kinds of
things and is related you know we can we
can help people in so many ways just by
you know controlling the organs or
trying to correct things in the brain
but yeah I mean I guess I I hope that
the future has a you know robust ethical
framework around this I mean I think
those decisions have to be made you know
you know by by individuals by in
Consulting with their doctors and that
you know
yeah I don't have an answer to that
because that's that's difficult but I
can say that this is coming and it's
probably coming within the next couple
of decades and so now is the time to be
talking about it so okay this is so far
off but I still gotta ask when you look
at the neurochemical interactions of the
brain and you look at what you're doing
in terms of recording it codifying it
and then manipulating it
wouldn't it be possible one day to take
that
and kind of change the way people think
because like for instance something like
racism which is an irrational response
to seeing someone different you would be
able to kind of dial that down so that
you might be able to eliminate certain
uh human maladies with with this type of
uh um technology or am I am I just to
sci-fi and and too bleeding heart
so uh that's that's a great question and
so there's a deep morality dimension of
that too because that means you're
controlling people's thoughts and you
have a nice Progressive uh mission
statement that we all you know Kumbaya
but that that but in the hands of
Nefarious
counterparts to Cynthia and Brock
you guys could start a revolution so so
yeah what do you what what's up with
that I I think it's like so many things
there there's probably a potential to do
bad and there's also a great potential
to do good so for example if someone is
addicted to drugs can we put a signal in
that helps them get better I was
involved in a trial where we put
electrodes in to try to help people with
otherwise incurable depression and and
help them access things like therapy so
all of these things have the potential
for good or bad
um frankly I'm hoping that Elementary
education gets rid of racism in this
country rather than having to put
electrodes in everyone's brain seems the
less risky uh approach I got to tell you
the way things are going I'm betting on
you
but Cynthia can you comment on the
ethics of this
yeah so I want to say you know right now
we're starting out with little little
demonstrations we're just getting
started with all of this but it is not
too early to emphasize the ethics and we
need to put a framework around this like
you know what what you said like
changing people's Thoughts by
stimulating that's possible we're doing
it we are exploring treatments and so we
need to put you know the the legal
framework the ethical framework
um to and we need to do that now and I
will say like right now we already have
like I love the FDA I I enjoy all of our
interactions right you know we we need
we need Regulatory Agencies like that
but you know but we need to start
exploring so I love the FDA but yeah
okay well but it's if we didn't have
them like like this stuff should have an
ethical framework around it and I I
don't think we've had enough of a
discussion as a society about what that
should look like let me just add this it
it's so important also to involve the
people that you're trying to help and
get their ideas
making sure that what what they want or
what we think will help them will
actually be of use to them and so that's
a whole other dimension right right
that's a good point you were both in the
field of biomedical electrical
engineering right hey is there a group
of chemical Engineers studying the same
thing and as it is it going to be
something like those joining forces that
brings this thing to a speedier
conclusion and gives you what ultimately
you're aiming for absolutely so one of
the most exciting things is that Cindy
and I don't operate in a vacuum we have
a whole team at the University of
Michigan there are probably 40
investigators who are in interested in
what I call restorative neuro
engineering and there are material
scientists there are chemists they're
electrical engineers there's data
scientists it's going to take the
combined efforts of all these different
fields uh to lick this problem
so generally that's enabled when there's
a journal that comes out that has all
those that has syllables extracted from
all those fields staple together into a
new word like biochemical engineering
all right I mean this has been all the
rage in the last several decades is how
you get uh uh you get astrophysics you
get biophysics you get geophysics you
get geochemistry so it sounds like you
guys need a little bit of everybody
to tackle the brain this this universe
probably won't need an astrophysicist
physics comes in here a lot totally I'm
always in with the physics I'm all in
with the Astro part astronaut so much
maybe a little less I have another
question because you've got my my new
brain spinning here um how are you
powering this I mean are we getting to
the point where you can solar power is
it close enough to the surface of the
skin and the connectivity are you at a
Bluetooth is this Wi-Fi enabled or is
this just basic Cape is this cable at
the moment are we how far along are we
on those two fronts yeah so so right now
every device that's inside of a person
today it's probably out it's got a
battery in it or it's got like a an RF
coil so it's you know radio frequency
power um there's a little bit of like
Optical powering
um where the powering gets really
exciting is we're trying to make these
implants tiny right so for example we're
trying to do uh infrared which passes
through tissue really well and we're
trying to use that to take our you know
bed of needles and make it a distributed
group of like lots of little nodes that
can record and those would get uh
infrared power but people have looked at
all kinds of things for this um
ultrasound like that's another way of
getting power into the body so but yeah
lots of lots of things I have too much
power around each electrode do you not
then run the risk of damaging cells well
and that's why the problems yes and
that's why you can't just you know power
everything from the outside like you can
always get power in there but the
question is did you deliver too much
power to the brain tissue in order to
power up your device we always want more
power we always want more people no no
no no no no
please go very wrong
no Neil you can't put a VA in there V8
isn't is an old fashioned internal
combustion engine or a car that has
eight Pistons so you guys remember those
yes dinosaurs used to drive them wait
Gary I got it I just got to ask just
just slip in so
Chuck just hinted at this earlier but I
want to make sure we we address this
because it especially affects
performance either intellectual or
athletic performance if you have the
power
to influence a human brain which is such
a big part of any form of human
performance what's to stop people
from making themselves better than they
ever would have been holding aside
whether they were injured or missing
limbs or had spinal cord injury just
right give me that I'm a I'm a a quote
average normal healthy human being still
give it to me so my reflexes are faster
so I can jump higher so that we all set
myself out in the big game we already
use
um you know chemicals to increase and
augment certain brain functions yes
90 of the game is half mental there you
go so like I want to implant that just
singularizes my focus focus yeah I
singularize my focus so that when you
throw a pitch at me all I see is like
the baseball is like biggest of
volleyball and the success are just
turning slowly right I can actually read
Rawlings
you know enhancing human performances on
the doorstep so where do you see that
taking place
yeah so I want to say for specifically
this
this involves doing surgery
we are not
it is it's nowhere near where we're at
you know we're trying to get bits per
second out of the brain right which is
amazing if you're trying to control a
prosthetic hand but not very helpful if
you're an athlete you know trying to
augment your performance
um I can say that there's every possible
kind of non-invasive way to do this is
being explored right now right there's
little headphones there's little things
you can wear on your forehead there's
earphones that you know theoretically
stimulate your brain there's where we
have some of the physics problems right
like you're just you know you're trying
to get a signal in or out that you know
maybe you can do something and it's
worth a try but like you know you're
probably not going to see that much
augmentation in the near future but deep
spring deep brain stimulation either by
electrodes that go deep in the brain or
by some like you're saying Cindy some
external device that focuses energy
super magnets yeah for example and I
mean probably not but yeah
so I always say that that augmentation
is is nowhere near where we're at you
know like 50 years like you know not
going to happen
um however this whole field didn't exist
20 years ago right and 20 years isn't I
blink right um so by the time you're
fast forwarding this technology I mean
like I I don't think that you know
there's going to be brain implants
anytime soon but
thousand years is a long time right and
there's there's maybe going to be other
ways of doing this that are more
non-invasive and more safe and so you
can never say never in engineering but
so so parag if we can actually make
permanent positive changes to the brain
then we stitch you back up and and
Cindy's out of a job because your brain
is doing it on its own
neurochemically rather than with
external help is that is is that where
you might Land one day yeah well so that
that's a another great question so one
of the things we do deep brain
stimulation for is for Parkinson's
Disease and to help patients who have
Parkinson's disease and people ask me
well what will you do if we find a cure
to Parkinson's disease who will you
operate on and the answer is I will
celebrate similarly if we find a way to
cure spinal cord injury I will celebrate
we will all celebrate there are so many
I'll start working on the problem of
chronic pain so yeah every technology it
creates many more opportunities than it
does limit our options but I didn't mean
to express sympathy for you guys being
out of a job that was was not my intent
here it was just I'm just imagining if
you have a cure for something then then
so much of what Cindy is describing is
no longer necessary that's all because
the body now handles it itself so that's
a foreseeable future as well is that
correct yeah
in a sense I mean you know where there's
people that are trying to
trying to court and there's people that
people that are around it and
went out of business but if it's just
electricity and and chemistry why can't
you just solder a new connection across
the broken spinal cord why is that so
hard get some physicists in there we do
this all the time okay some Electronics
people this could be a soldering iron
unfortunately it's much easier to do
with biological components so like I I'm
a fan of the wires right we're trying to
get wires in
um but probably it's better if it's like
neurons and axons and you can reform the
connections make new synapses
um but on the other hand you still have
the patterning problem right like they
have to know where to go and so people
are using electricity to try to guide
like you know regrowth of the spinal
cord for example
Neil we're right on the doorstep we just
need three things we need
the wire we need the soldering iron and
we need the wiring diagram once you give
us those three things we're there oh and
it sounds like the wiring diagram is the
tough one at this point yeah yeah all
right that's that's hard to get back
once you've lost it whoa yeah
that is everything so just
pointing that out
right there we only did three things I'm
like yeah that's everything
no but it's deep that you can even list
three things I mean I think it's no no
and it's and you can abstract those
categories to many other walks of life
all right yeah uh you need the tool you
need the the materials the tools and and
the the diagram I mean I think that's
that that applies to everything but the
cool thing is that though
every advancement you make touches upon
other areas of Our Lives there's it's an
advancement everywhere yes any
advancements where you are as an
advancement of Science and Engineering
that's that's the Hallmark of what that
what that is yeah well it's the rising
tide isn't it this is rising tide that
raises All Ships so yes it's just the
benefit of this work I think one of the
most exciting things is we currently
have techno Technologies like deep brain
stimulation that can really help people
with otherwise untreatable problems like
Parkinson's disease the challenge is
that only about one in ten people who
could benefit from the technology
actually have the therapy and so there's
a big public awareness problem and so if
we can inform people it would just be
great so so Cindy and uh parag how do we
find you on social media or or your lab
it does it have a a home on on the
internet yeah I I have a great last name
for science so
um it was it's a recent immigrant
misspelling so if you search a chestic
you get me and my brother and so and
that's it that's it and nobody else yeah
so yeah so so Google I'm very Googling
yeah so my lab and you know all the
wonderful students you know I I don't do
any of this work they do all of it and
I'm always looking for uh new trainees
and new students that's what students
are for are these the students who you
put the electrodes in or
[Laughter]
how do we find your work well if similar
to Cindy uh p-a-t-i-l if you Google that
in Michigan neurosurgery my email will
pop up guys this has been a delightful
interview I'd love learning about where
we are and where we're going in not only
engineering but in all the sciences and
uh you know Gary Chuck this is going to
show up in sports very soon yes and
hopefully it will show up in Not Just
Sports but across the whole spectrum of
society in such a bountiful Plus for so
many people all right guys this has been
great uh Chuck always good to have you
again always a pleasure um pleasure Ian
parag all right we'll we'll we'll track
your work and if you get any new uh
please give us give us a call we'll put
you right back on there oh yeah thank
you thanks so much for having me
like this thank you so much has been
StarTalk sports edition you know the
grass Tyson here your personal
astrophysicist keep looking up
[Music]